[Música]
i
alguna vez le hicieron alguna pregunta
que los incómodo
a mí hace cuatro años me hicieron una
se acercó un amigo un colono una persona
de la chacra de alem acá en misiones
y vino a contarme que estuvo viendo un
documental de américa y de áfrica
y veía como había gente que pasaba
hambre en estos lugares
y me dice matías me dolió mucho ver
gente que pase hambre cuando yo acá en
la chacra tengo un montón de productos
que no puedo venderlos que no sé dónde
ubicarlos
porque no tengo logística porque no
tengo mercado
y me largo una pregunta que me incomodó
desde ese día
no puede ser que yo por no vender
mis productos terminé tirando la comida
a los chanchos y los chanchos coman
mejor que la gente
desde ese momento empezamos a ver qué
podíamos hacer con esos productos
y cómo hacer también para que desde alem
se pueden llevar alimentos a todo el
mundo es allí cuando descubrimos una
técnica importante para que estos
alimentos puedan salir de alem de
emisiones hacia el mundo a través de un
proceso que se llama liofilización
la liofilización es muy común para que
se conserven lo que ustedes se aplican
cuando son chicos que son las famosas
vacunas con muchos medicamentos y
nosotros encontramos a esa metodología
para poder conservar alimentos que es lo
que es la liofilización hablando en
criollo la impresión lo que hace es
deshidratar los alimentos con frío y con
vacío encontramos la forma de cómo hacer
para conservar estos alimentos y también
encontramos
a nuestras comidas regionales logro una
cazuela de mondongo un guiso arriesgas
un buen poroto con arroz para poder
hacer que estas comidas las podamos
llevar a distintos lugares del mundo
qué ventaja tiene la liofilización es
que conserva deshidratada esta comida
ya hecha la lista que solamente tienen
que ponerle agua
un tiempo de hasta 20 años y ustedes que
son gente joven seguramente tras unos 20
años
y yo me imagino hoy preparar la comida
y con la gran aplicación face up
imaginarme cómo seré yo dentro de 20
años con la misma comida que sería algo
más o menos así
el mundo cada vez
es más injusto hay cada vez mayores
desigualdades hay cada vez más gente que
tiene menos y menos gente que tiene más
hay una gran realidad el mundo tiene hoy
6000 millones de personas habitando lo
imagínense un 6 seguido de 12 ceros un
número bastante interesante bastante
complejo
pero un dato que no es menor vamos a
imaginarnos que ustedes son el mundo y
que en el mundo hay 100 personas ustedes
son 100 personas de esas 100 personas
hoy 15 este sector acá no va a comer hoy
y tampoco va a comer mañana y tampoco va
a comer pasado este número de 15
personas que te lo estoy resumiendo es
el equivalente a 850 millones de
personas por día que pasan hambre y
pasar hambre realmente es una tragedia
es un gran problema cada persona que
pasa hambre no se desarrolla cada
persona que pasa hambre tiene que estar
pensando en lo urgente en alimentarse
pero no son todo malas noticias
argentina y el mundo producen muchos
alimentos el mundo genera alimentos para
toda la población argentina produce
alimentos
para cuatro veces la población y
misiones nuestra tierra también tiene un
gran aporte para hacer desde el
industrial desde poder empezar a generar
con esa pujanza que vinieron nuestros
inmigrantes la gente que vino a forjar
esta tierra y ese
calorcito que nos da la tierra colorada
el poder empezar a generar alimentos
también para el mundo
tenemos ríos tenemos caminos estamos en
un lugar estratégico misiones está en el
medio de un lugar a 300 km de una
capital de un país como paraguay
a kilómetros escasos de un país como es
brasil cerquita de chaco y cerquita de
corrientes tenemos todo
es por eso
que nosotros decidimos crear comida por
un dólar con la idea de un triple
impacto
de que la gente no pase hambre de que la
gente cuando coma una ración de comida
un guiso un locro que podrá hasta 20
años tenga vitaminas se alimente y se
nutra el primer impacto segundo
ver esos hitos que están dando vuelta y
todos me refiero a ese productor que
vino a decirme que no puede ser que los
chanchos como mejor que la gente con su
producto darle valor agregado y también
generar mano de obra genuina y que se
vaya replicando nuestra fábrica es una
empresa social somos un proyecto social
único en el país pero con la ventaja y
la idea de que se puede replicar en
distintos lugares de argentina o del
mundo
con lo cual nosotros estamos muy pero
muy orgullosos de eso le pusimos comida
por un dólar
este se preguntarán por qué porque es un
valor universal porque un dólar se
utiliza en argentina en la china en
cualquier lugar del mundo en paraguay en
brasil pues también para demostrar que
con un dólar
una persona puede estar alimentada y
segundo que cuando esa persona esté
comiendo esa ración de comida sepa que
alguien pagó por esa ración no más que
un dólar
con esto nosotros queremos ocuparnos de
lo urgente que es lo urgente que la
gente tenga la panza llena
que la persona a partir de ahí se puede
ocupar de lo importante
cuántas veces escuchamos decir que vaya
a conseguir trabajo pero si una persona
no comió lo más probable que lo que esté
pensando es en llenar la panza suya y
sobre todo de sus hijos cuando tiene la
panza llena se ocupa de lo importante y
se ocupa también de desarrollarse de
educarse de capacitarse y de poder dar
un aporte a la sociedad hoy todos
tenemos formas de dar aporte
todos somos buenos en algo todos podemos
generar ustedes son un potencial que
puede generar y vuelvo a la pregunta
que así inicialmente alguna vez le
hicieron a pregunta que los incómodos
y se les agregó otra pregunta más
qué hicieron con esa pregunta nada más
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]